well many of you are waiting for
unemployment's benefits want to know how
much longer you could be waiting
eight news now reporter joe moeller gets
dozens of emails and messages
from our viewers on a daily basis about
the weight he spoke with top deter
officials today asking your questions
he now joins us live with those answers
joe
well we are trying to answer as many
questions as possible today we did speak
to
dieter officials like you had mentioned
and they they do know that there's still
a lot of people out there waiting for
their benefits and they're hoping to get
to those people who have been waiting
for several months here in the next few
weeks
in pua at least we're getting very close
to having a resolution for
most of the folks who have come in from
the backlog of claims to additional
staff i discussed a number of topics for
the deter director and strike force
leader
between the staffing and the automation
again we're hoping to see
large amounts of clearances in the next
two weeks
many who filed several months ago are
waiting for their claims to be processed
strike force leader barbara buckley says
they are working to find the claims that
they think could have fell through the
cracks
is there any time frame you could put on
that
yeah i mean it's our hope for the pua
system
to do all of these in the next two weeks
i mean we feel like we're at the bottom
of of uh resolution for pua
and then we want to put the extra
resources the labor
on the ui claims overpayment notices
went out earlier this week
that was because you either were
claiming in pua or regular ui when you
were supposed to be in the other
or your income didn't match the
documents submitted many say they are
being asked to pay money that they did
not get
if the system generated an overpayment
notice and someone to
get the money they should appeal that
because it's wrong and it will be
corrected
they say they expect to process more
pending appeals soon
we have had a few hundred scheduled
and we we know we have about seven or
eight hundred that are
sort of ready to go
we did touch on a number of other topics
including lost wages the fifth week and
also those phone lines and when the best
time is to call during the week
you can find the complete interview up
on our website that is eight newsnow dot
com
reporting live joe muller 8 news now